ROY FULLER: We're good to go.
NEVIN HEINTZE: All right.
Thank you very much, Roy.
And thanks, everyone,
for your time,
and welcome to this session
on Spanner migration.
So good afternoon to everyone
in the West Coast, and evening
if you're on the East Coast.
And I'm actually from
Sydney, so it's morning here.
I'm Nevin Heintze.
I'm a senior engineer at
Google working on Spanner.
And my focus is on
database migration.
So today, we're going to
discuss migration to Spanner.
And I'm going to give an
overview of typical steps
in a migration.
And then we're going
to do a deep dive
into some of the core
parts of a migration.
And then I'm going to describe
best practices and also
some migration tools.
Now just a heads-up.
I think we advertised
this as 30 minutes.
I probably have actually
about 25 minutes of material.
So with questions,
just sort of a heads-up
and an apology in
advance, we're probably
going to spill a little
bit over the 30 minutes.
So we might get to 35 or
40 minutes, so apologies
in advance.
OK, so here's a typical set
of steps in a migration.
And these steps are fairly
independent of the source
and target databases involved.
And I'm sure for some
of you, these steps
will be very familiar.
What I'm going to do
is go over these steps
and highlight them from the
perspective of migrations
to Spanner.
And I'm particularly going to
focus on migrations from MySQL
to Spanner.
Most migrations start with
some kind of assessment phase.
And the goal here is to
determine if the target
database-- in this
case, Spanner--
is likely to be a good fit.
Will it provide the
necessary functionality?
Will it meet the
cost-performance requirements?
How much work will
the migration be?
What are the biggest risks?
What are the biggest benefits?
The next step is often
a proof of concept.
And in many ways, this
is sort of an extension
of the assessment.
So it's typical for
a proof of concept
to focus on key items that
come from the assessment,
like what are the biggest risks?
Or confirming that the main
benefits of the migration
can be delivered.
So for example,
many Spanner users
see Spanner's ability to scale
as one of its main benefits.
And so their POCs often focus
on evaluating Spanner's ability
to scale for their use case.
The next step, step
3 on this slide,
is the core part of the
migration preparation,
so the design and
implementation of the migration.
This can have many components.
But there are three
common themes.
The first is designing an
appropriate Spanner schema.
The next is determining
how data will
be moved from MySQL to Spanner
and building components
to support this move.
And the third is
application changes
to switch over to using Spanner.
This can range from migrating
queries, to code changes,
to switching from MySQL's
APIs to using Spanner's APIs.
And it could potentially involve
application modernization.
The next step, step 4,
is testing in dry runs.
Now successful migrations
involve significant testing,
either using test traffic or
parts of your production load.
And it's common for these
two steps, steps 3 and 4,
to be intermixed.
So you might have an initial
design and an implementation,
try it out, find
issues, and then go back
and do some redesign,
change some implementation.
Maybe you find a
performance issue and you
need to go back and
tweak the schema,
and, for example, add an index.
So this is really an iterative
process between steps 3 and 4.
Many migrations have a
target day for moving data
or for completing the
move and switching over
to using Spanner.
So this becomes a
really critical day,
a convergence of
all of the planning
and execution phases
of a migration.
And there's usually
a substantial amount
of planning around what
happens on this day,
with detailed schedules, kind
of all hands on deck situation.
And a key part of
this is knowing
how to respond if things
don't go according to plan.
What signals and dashboards
should we be looking at?
What's the criteria
for reverting?
How do we revert?
I want to emphasize that all
of the steps I've listed here,
you shouldn't take this
as too prescriptive,
because every migration
is going to be different.
And which steps are
important, which
have the biggest
risks, which take
the most time will
vary significantly
from one migration to another.
So over the next few
slides, I'm going
to do a deep dive into
each of these steps.
So as we discussed
earlier, most migrations
start with some kind
of assessment phase.
And there's a basic
question we want to answer.
Is Spanner a good choice?
A common starting
point is an analysis
of what MySQL
features are actually
being used, what types, and
indexes, and queries are used.
What about stored
procedures, stored functions?
What about auto-increment?
And based on this
analysis, we need
to determine how well these
features map onto Spanner.
So Spanner supports
most core types,
but not some of the
more exotic types--
geometry types and point types--
that MySQL has.
Spanner also doesn't
support stored procedures.
And the usual solution there
is to pull that functionality
into application code.
Auto-increment and
sequences are not
supported in Spanner, either.
And these are
challenging to handle
at scale because of the hot
spots they can generate.
We recommend using
random generation of IDs
to spread the load
across the key space,
and there are several
other alternatives.
There are differences
between the query dialect
of MySQL and Spanner.
So for some migrations,
query translation
is a really critical component.
It's worth emphasizing that
there's a huge variation here
between different MySQL users.
Some use a very broad
set of MySQL features,
and others essentially only
use MySQL as a key-value store,
just using very basic types.
One trend we've observed
from MySQL users who
want to migrate to Spanner
is that they typically
have very large MySQL
databases and they're hitting
MySQL scalability limits.
They're often using sharding and
have multiple MySQL replicas.
As a result, they often limit
their use of MySQL features
that don't scale well,
such as stored procedures,
triggers, auto-increment.
And they often have very highly
optimized queries, especially
for their core high
QPS operations.
So this often minimizes the
role of complex queries,
complex joins, and
full table scans.
I want to briefly touch
on transaction semantics
and locking.
So those of you who
are familiar with MySQL
will know that this is a
really complicated topic.
The default MySQL isolation
level is repeatable reads,
and most MySQL servers
run with this default.
This isolation
level does, indeed,
provide repeatable
read semantics
for standard SQL queries.
However, the picture gets
much more complicated
for DML statements and for SQL
queries that require locks.
Such statements are
essentially executed
using read committed semantics.
So it's not uncommon
for MySQL users
to employ sophisticated
locking strategies
to ensure the transaction
semantics they need
or to implement safety checks
to identify and correct
anomalies due to, for
example, lost updates
or read or write skew.
In contrast, Spanner provides
a simple, robust transaction
model, which is serializability.
So all transactions
appear as they
were executed in
serial order, even
if some of the reads and
writes of distinct transactions
actually occur in parallel.
In other words, anomalies
like lost updates,
random reads, read skew,
write skew, and so forth don't
happen in Spanner.
This can significantly
simplify code for managing logs
or for managing MySQL
transaction anomalies.
Note that transactions
do occasionally fail,
and are rolled back in Spanner,
and have to be retried.
So it's really
important that your code
base and the libraries you use,
that together, they provide
the appropriate retry logic.
OK, so another important
aspect of assessment
is looking at how your
applications communicate
with MySQL.
What drivers do they use?
Do they use ORMs?
Are those supported by Spanner?
Finally, an assessment
usually contains an analysis
of the benefits
of using Spanner.
So what are the
key features that
are driving the
adoption of Spanner?
It might be scalability,
or that Spanner
is a fully managed
service with no downtime,
or it may be just the high
availability of Spanner
that provides four 9's up
time for regional instances
and five 9's up time for our
multi-region configurations.
We'll talk a little
more about HarbourBridge
later, but I want to
note here that one
of the core features
of HarbourBridge
is that it automatically
generates an assessment
report from a MySQL database
So moving on to step
2, as we noted before,
it is typical for
a proof of concept
to almost be an extension
of an assessment.
So the role of the POC is often
to scope out the biggest risks,
validate the main benefits.
And it's quite common
for a Spanner posse
to focus on scalability,
to establish
that Spanner can scale to
your needs and workload.
Given Spanner's
virtually unbounded
scalability capabilities,
demonstrating this
is not usually an
issue, although we
have seen some cases
where hidden limitations
or constraints on
the customer's side
can lead to apparent
scalability limits.
And then it's a matter
of debugging a system end
to end to find out where
in the customer's stack
the issue is, or in network
configuration, and so on.
Another aspect of the POC is
figuring out sizing estimates.
So how many Spanner nodes will
be required for the workload?
Sizing of any database
is workload-dependent,
and Spanner is no exception.
We provide some rules of
thumb for basic workloads.
But we always strongly
recommend that you run tests
with your workload.
And this is often
part of the POC.
Implicit in most POCs is
learning about Spanner.
So it's common for our users to
get valuable Spanner experience
during the POC, and build their
level of comfort and confidence
that Spanner will work for them.
A couple of high level planning
aspects of a POC that are worth
mentioning.
So it's really
important to establish
a clear scope of the POC.
Don't try to address all
issues and solve all problems.
But it's critical
to limit the scope
to just the important issues.
And of course, to have a
well-defined and realistic
success criteria for the POC.
The next step, step
3, is the core part
of the migration preparation,
the design and implementation
of the migration.
There's a lot we
could talk about here,
but I'm going to focus
on three common tasks--
schema migration,
data migration,
and application migration.
And we're going to talk
about schema migration first.
That is, what we want to do
is design an efficient Spanner
schema to meet the application
and workload needs.
The starting point here is
usually types, and columns,
and tables to support
the application needs.
But really, critical
elements of the design
are around primary keys.
So these have to be
designed for scalability,
and in particular
to avoid hot spots.
And of course, they need
to be designed to be
appropriate for the query load.
So it's not uncommon
for problems
to surface months
after a migration that
can be tracked back to issues
with primary key design.
So this is a really
critical thing to get right.
Much of schema design is
driven by query performance.
So the role of secondary
indexes is very critical.
And Spanner provides some
unique capabilities to optimize
queries-- so for example, using
interleaved tables to control
the layout of data
between related tables--
and this can provide significant
query performance boosts
for joins, as well
as for writes.
Inherent in schema design
is managing trade-offs,
such as the cost of reeds
versus the cost of writes.
For example, I might
add a secondary index
to improve my read
performance, but this
means that my writes will
become more expensive.
So in Spanner, a
secondary index is
implemented as a Spanner table.
So when I add a secondary
index to a table,
then any row I add to that
table actually adds two rows.
It adds one row
to the base table
and another one to
the index table.
So if I have many
secondary indexes,
then my writes can
become very expensive.
And it's really critical to
balance these trade-offs.
And this is particularly
true if you're
moving from MySQL, where
the balance in costs
between indexes and reads
is a little different.
So this is something that,
coming from a MySQL background,
pay particular attention to.
The next task we're going to
discuss is data migration.
And we could have a whole
workshop on data migration,
so I'm only going to skim over
some really high level choices
here.
In short, there are
many alternatives.
But in most cases,
business needs
or application architecture will
quickly narrow down the choices
that you have.
So I'm just going to
start with the simplest,
most basic migration strategy,
which is stop and copy.
So obviously, a
big downside here
is that you need to
stop your application
for a period of time,
maybe a few hours or more.
And the basic idea is
stop everything, copy over
all the data from
MySQL to Spanner,
and then startup your
applications again.
So the beauty of this
approach is that simplicity.
However, most online
databases can't
be migrated this
way, because they
can't tolerate the downtime.
But if you can, seriously
consider doing stop and copy.
The more common
approach, particularly
for migrating online databases,
is the so-called zero downtime
approach.
So in this approach, you
first take a snapshot
of your MySQL database and
you start copying it over
to Spanner.
While that's ongoing, you
capture all of the real-time
changes using Change
Data Capture--
CDC.
And you can either
replay them to Spanner
while the initial
load is ongoing,
or you can store the
CDC stream and replay it
after the initial
load is complete.
There are some
trade-offs involved here
and there are also some
important data consistency
issues to get right.
For example, if the
initial load and CDC
writes happen at
the same time, you
need to ensure that old
data from the initial load
doesn't overwrite incoming
new data from CDC.
In any case, when the
initial snapshot load and CDC
load are complete,
there is a short period
when you stop the
MySQL database,
let the CDC stream
drain to Spanner,
and then switch over
applications to Spanner.
This switchover time
can be a few minutes
to maybe tens of minutes.
So there's some downtime, but
it's typically fairly small.
Another approach I want to
briefly mention is dual writes.
So in this case, you
modify the application
stack to write to both MySQL
and to Spanner at the same time.
So this also requires an
initial load of data to Spanner
and some synchronization between
the initial load and the dual
writes to ensure data integrity.
The main benefit
of this approach
is that it allows you to run
both databases in parallel
and to switch from
MySQL to Spanner,
and back again, if needed.
However, this can be pretty
costly in terms of resources.
And there are some
other really difficult
technical issues to resolve,
and that's around failures.
So what happens if you're
committing a transaction
and the transaction
succeeds in one database
and fails in the other?
How do you recover?
I see the question.
Let me postpone
that until the end
and I'll get back
to that question.
Another approach is
incremental migration.
And this is not a
fully general solution,
but it can be really useful
for some applications.
And I've seen this used in a
number of different contexts.
So the core starting
point is to have
a highly partitioned database.
So for example, the database
might map IDs of some kind
to data about those IDs,
and where each ID is
independent of other IDs.
So in particular, we need
for a update to the database
to involve just a single ID.
In other words, we don't
have any multi-ID update
transactions.
Then what you can do
is you can pick an ID,
copy its data from
MySQL over to Spanner,
and that's usually
pretty quick, maybe even
a few tens of milliseconds.
And then from that point on,
you serve that ID from Spanner.
And if needed, you can actually
move this ID back from Spanner
to MySQL.
The core of this approach
is an ID-to-database mapping
that has to be maintained
so that you know,
at all times, which
database actually
owns that particular ID.
The next step I want to
mention in the design
and implementation phase
is application migration.
And again, this is a
really large topic,
and I'm just going to
touch on a few aspects.
So the first is around
application code changes.
So what will be needed here
is going to heavily depend
on what drivers the
application uses
and whether an ORM is used.
So some database users
structure their applications
around a database
abstraction layer,
which is an
application-specific set of APIs
that abstract the
core operations
needed from the database.
And this can be a huge
help for migration,
since it localizes the
database-specific code
to a small set of APIs.
So application
migration can now focus
on just rewriting those
APIs or the implementation
of those APIs to use Spanner.
But the other extreme,
some applications
spread their database code
throughout the application.
And this can lead to really very
time-consuming and complex code
migrations.
We briefly mentioned before
that MySQL and Spanner have
different SQL query dialects.
So each query used
in an application
needs to be checked
and potentially
rewritten to use with Spanner.
So sometimes, this is
fairly straightforward.
Sometimes, it can be
a huge amount of work.
It depends on the structure
of the application.
Finally, I wanted to briefly
mention stored procedures.
These are not
supported by Spanner.
And the usual approach
is to rewrite them
as application code.
It goes without
saying that testing
is fundamental to a
successful migration.
And this can either use
test traffic or parts
of your production load.
If it is test traffic,
it's really very important
to ensure that the test
traffic realistically
models the production setup.
And if it's part of
your production load,
then it's really important
that the part that you use
be representative
of your full load.
And as I mentioned earlier,
it's common for steps 3 and 4
to be intermixed.
So you might have an initial
design and an implementation.
Try it out.
Find issues.
And then go back
and do some redesign
and change the implementation.
Maybe you find
performance issues.
You need to tweak the
schema, for example.
So this is really an
iterative process.
Now we come to
the exciting part,
actually doing the migration.
So first, a quick comment.
Not every migration will
have a migration day.
So for example, if you use
incremental data migration,
then your migration
is essentially
an incremental,
continuous process.
It might have a start
day and an end day,
but that could be weeks,
maybe even months apart.
However, many migrations
do have a target day
for moving or
completing data move
and switching over
to using Spanner.
And this becomes a
really critical day.
Here's where you find out if
all of your planning and testing
have been effective.
And obviously, you
really want migration day
to be problem-free.
One of the very important
aspects of migration day
is knowing what to do if
you run into problems.
First, how do we
know if things are OK
or if there is a problem?
What signals and dashboards
should we be looking at?
What thresholds are acceptable?
Who is the decision-maker
for reverting?
How do we revert?
And it's critical that
the revert process
has been well-tested.
So one thing to
consider, especially
for gaming applications,
is database warmup.
So for example, suppose we're
migrating a game platform
from MySQL to Spanner,
and we're going
to launch with a new game.
So we've gone through all of
the tasks of schema migration
and application migration,
but we don't actually
have any data, because
this is a new game.
So our tables are empty.
Spanner's load-balancing
mechanisms
respond to load signals.
And we'll talk about this in
a little more detail later.
But the point is that
these mechanisms take time
to respond to load changes.
And generally, this
is not an issue,
because they respond
fairly quickly,
on the order of a few minutes.
But if the tables
are empty, then it
can take several iterations of
these load-balancing mechanisms
before we can adapt to the
full load of a game launch.
So to address this, we
need to warmup the tables.
And basically, this
is typically done
by prepopulating the
tables with synthetic data
and adding load to
stimulate Spanner's
load-balancing mechanisms,
and then the synthetic data
can be deleted.
If a database is
already populated
with data as part
of a data migration,
then warmup is
usually not needed,
because there's already enough
splits and enough warmup
of the database because
of the load of the data.
The next couple
of slides, I'm got
to address some low level
details of migrations,
specifically from
MySQL to Spanner.
And I want to first
have a look at types.
So Spanner provides coverage
of the core types of MySQL.
However, you'll
notice that, where
MySQL has many different
integer types, for example,
Spanner has just one, int64.
So similarly for
floating point numbers
and for chars and text types.
There's just one
float type in Spanner
and there's just
one string type,
although it's a string
type, but it has a parameter
with a length limit.
MySQL also has a
variety of other types,
such as geometry types,
point, line, and so on.
Spanner doesn't provide a
corresponding type for these,
and we usually recommend using
either string or bytes here.
Let's dig a little bit into
the design of primary keys.
And in order to do
this, I first need
to talk about splits
and their role,
and then we'll come back and
talk about best practices
for primary keys.
So some of the material
here has already
been covered in previous
Spanner meetups,
but I'll briefly recap the idea.
So in Spanner, the
primary key space
of each table in a
database is partitioned
into chunks, called splits.
So in this example, the
primary key is an integer
and the first split ranges from
minus infinity to minus 100,
the next split from minus
99 to 3,000, and so on.
So the same basic thing
happens across other types,
whether they be
strings or floats,
and also for multi-column
primary keys.
Each zone has a
copy of each split.
So I have a very
simple layout here
for a single-region
Spanner instance,
where we have three zones,
Zone A, Zone B, and Zone C.
And each zone has a
copy of every split.
So here's Split 0 in Zone
A. Here's Split 0 in Zone B.
And here's Split 0
in Zone C. And that
could be distributed somewhat
randomly across the Spanner
servers in each zone.
So the key point is that
each zone has full coverage
of the key space of a table.
And indeed, it has a full
copy of the table's data.
So you can think of
each zone as essentially
a standalone
replica, and Spanner
ensures that each
replica stays in sync
and has exactly the
same committed data.
So what's the role of splits?
Well, there were really
two parts to this.
The first is that splits are
the basis for distributing table
data across Spanner servers.
And the second is that they
form a core part of an automated
sharding mechanism to balance
load across Spanner servers.
So splits are not static,
unlike in many other databases
and sharding databases.
So in Spanner, splits
are not static.
They're continually on the
move and they're continually
evolving.
So for example, if a split is
hot and receiving lots of load
or contains lots of data, it'll
be split into smaller splits.
And if two neighboring splits
have been relatively inactive
for a long time, then
they'll be merged.
So the core ideas behind
splits were actually
developed as part of
Bigtable many years ago,
and they've been
adopted and extended
to form a core part of Spanner.
Based on our
understanding of splits,
we can come back
to the question,
what makes a good primary key?
And very simply put,
a good primary key
is one that spreads the key
values over the key space.
So names are usually
a good primary key,
unless everyone has the same
name or very similar names.
And hashes are also an
excellent primary key.
What we want to avoid is
primary keys that clump together
some aspect of the
lifecycle of table rows,
whether that be creation of
rows, or updates and reads,
or deletions.
So for example,
auto-increment keys
are problematic, because with
auto-increment, all new rows
will be in exactly the
same part of the key space.
So this will cause a hot
spot for row creation
for inserting into the database.
And in fact, with
auto-increment, they'll
actually appear
in the same split
and it'll be held in
the same Spanner server.
So more generally, we want
to design our primary keys
to avoid hot spots.
I mentioned several tools
for assisting with migration,
and I'm going to conclude
with a little more detail
of these tools and
their capabilities.
I've mentioned
HarbourBridge several times.
So HarbourBridge is
an open-source tool.
It's used for various
stages of migration.
It can be used for assessment.
It can be used for schema
migration, for data migration.
So here's a sample workflow,
where HarbourBridge is run
and it ingests data from a
MySQL or Postgres database.
And we can either
use dump formats,
like mysqldump or
pg_dump, or directly
access the database
using SELECT queries
and extract schema information
using information schema
tables.
It builds a Spanner
schema, creates a database,
and populates it with data
from the source database.
And then it documents that
run with a detailed assessment
report that includes potential
issues with type mappings,
highlights MySQL features
that are used by the source
database that are not
supported by Spanner,
and also logs any
errors encountered.
So HarbourBridge can also be
used to browse and customize
your Spanner schema in what
we call Schema Assistant mode.
The other two tools I want to
highlight focus on data import.
The first is a bulk
data import tool,
and this is part of Google's
generic Dataflow service, which
is a unified, streaming, and
batch processing service.
So this service supports bulk
data import into Spanner.
And supported formats
include Avro and CSV.
And the second tool I want to
mention is a CDC import tool.
So this is part of
our generic DataStream
service, which is a change
data capture and replication
service.
And this service supports
MySQL to Spanner CDC,
amongst other combinations.
Let me stop here, and many
thanks for your attention.
And I'll invite
questions and comments.
And let me go over to the chat.
And I think there was at least
one question there from Andrew.
So Andrew asks,
would you advocate
any small-scale
migration testing
using the Spanner emulator?
It's actually two questions.
Let me talk about the emulator.
So the emulator is a
really fantastic piece
of technology for testing
things out and testing out
functionality.
I would be careful,
though, of what--
if you're doing a migration,
then you typically
want to understand throughput
and performance issues.
And the emulator is not
going to help you with those.
So view the emulator as a
really faithful reproduction
of Spanner's functionality--
so for testing code,
testing different scenarios.
But usually in a
migration, as I said,
you're really interested in
understanding scalability,
throughput, and performance.
And the emulator is not going
to be able to help you there.
So a qualified yes.
Definitely use the emulator
where it's appropriate.
But I would not encourage
using the emulator
as your only testing environment
for migration testing.
OK, how would you handle
application code changes
for transactions that hit
the 20,000 mutation limit?
Yeah, that's an
interesting question.
So I guess I have a
question in response,
and that is there are
a number of other tools
that we have for doing
large-scale mutations.
And in particular, we have
ways of doing partitioned DML.
The partitioned DML
is typically used
when you want to make
a large-scale change
across the entire database.
And the partitioned DML allows
you to basically carve up
the overall operation that you
want to do into smaller pieces.
And so that way, we get around
the 20,000 mutation limit,
because we're actually
splitting up the operation
into multiple transactions.
So if you can use
it, partitioned
DML is definitely a
very convenient tool
and will solve the
problem you have.
The main constraints
around partitioned
DML are the restrictions on
what kinds of DML operations
you can use it for.
So if you've got something that
you can't use partitioned DML,
then the main operation
or the main approach
that's open to you is
to basically split it up
into smaller sets of mutations.
So basically, split it up
into smaller transactions.
And that may require some code
change or some manual teasing
apart of this large operation.
So maybe Andrew, do you
have some more background
you can give on the particular
use case that you have?
OK.
And Andrew also mentions--
OK, no problem.
Andrew also mentions in
the data streaming space,
there's [INAUDIBLE].
Any other questions
live or anything anyone
wants to either ask about
or to give feedback on?
Yes.
[? Swara ?] asks, will
there be any SQL rewrite
required from MySQL to Spanner?
Yeah, I mentioned that part of a
migration from MySQL to Spanner
can potentially involve
having to rewrite SQL queries.
Spanner and MySQL have somewhat
different SQL dialects.
And so if you're using
very basic SQL constructs,
those may well be
fairly easy or maybe not
require change at all.
But it's quite common
for MySQL applications
that use a lot of
different SQL constructs.
That requires a substantial
amount of rewrite.
OK, so the follow-up question.
How much percentage
do we need to cover up
on the migration strategy?
I"m not quite sure I answered--
I'm not quite sure I
follow the question.
Do you mean how much is the
query rewrite of the migration?
Or are you referring--
[? Swara, ?] do you
mind clarifying that?
Oh, it's a SQL rewrite.
Yes, that depends tremendously
on the particular application.
So I have seen application
migrations where the SQL
rewrite was very
straightforward,
and particular
applications that were
organized around some sort of
database abstraction layer.
I've heard a number
of Spanner users
who were very
easily able to move
from MySQL over to Spanner,
from a query perspective.
But I also know customers who
have spent a substantial amount
of time on this.
So it's hard to give
an exact percentage,
because there's a huge variation
across different customers.
So I think some
good starting points
in estimating this
are around, well,
how many different
queries do you have?
And how many different
kinds of queries?
And what kinds of features
of Spanner are those--
sorry, what kinds of features of
MySQL are those queries using?
And then look to see at how
the features that you're
using in your MySQL queries--
how those features map
onto Spanner features.
So if you're doing very simple
things like standard SELECTs,
then that's going to be very
easy to migrate over to Spanner
and may not require
any changes at all.
If you're using a lot of
internal MySQL operations, so
built-in functions--
if you're using
a lot of built-in
functions, then you'll
need to see how they
map over to Spanner.
Sometimes, the syntax
is completely identical.
Sometimes, for
built-in functions,
there are variations
in the naming
of the built-in functions.
And some built-in
functions of MySQL
are not supported in Spanner.
So that's another aspect to
look at, to look at the queries
that you have and
look at the features
that you're using in MySQL.
Andrew follows up to
the earlier question.
To the earlier question,
I think you're mostly
around third-party
applications or ORMs, where
one can't as easily control
the size of the transaction.
Yeah, look, I agree with you.
This is an issue.
We're more than happy
to work with you
on finding solutions and
understanding more about it.
We recognize that this is an
issue and something that we're
working on to
increase the limits.
We don't have any commits.
We don't have any dates.
We don't have any
announcements on this.
But we're well
aware of the issue.
So Andrew, I definitely
strongly encourage you
to interact with
the Spanner team,
either with me or other
people in the Spanner team,
or with your point of
contact on the sales side.
We'd love to hear more about
the problems that you're having.
And I completely
agree, when you're
using a third-party
tool or an ORM,
you often don't have
the control over this.
So yeah, please, please
get in touch with us.
And I think it'll depend on
the specifics of the problem
that you have.
Any other questions?
Thank you, [? Swara ?]
and Andrew.
Well, thank you
everybody for attending.
And I think if there
are no other questions,
we will wrap it up.
Thanks, and thanks,
Roy, for hosting.
ROY FULLER: Absolutely.
Thank you, Nevin, and thank
you, everyone, for joining.
I will end the
recording right now.
Thank you all.